quand elle avait 30 ans les Québécois
disaient Fabienne Thibault c'est mes
deux chanteuses préférées
[Applaudissements]
alors tu faisais quoi toi pour grossir
moi pour grossir
le truc sur lequel tu craques même quand
tu t'es dit je fais un régime je fais un
régime je fais un régime c'est quoi moi
c'est les commentaires
s'il y a pas de mystère il faut manger
moins il faut diminuer la porte
calorique
tout ça bon mais il faut manger moins il
faut manger des spectacles
en parlant de spectacle il paraît qu'en
plein milieu de ton spectacle tu
t'arrêtes et que tu imites tes copines
du métier ça fait quoi quand tu fais ça
oh bah là ça c'est il y a quelques
années
la France par exemple comment tu le fais
chanter et que chacun se met à tenté
les laisser partir
Roch Voisine
[Applaudissements]
là c'était pas
je fais des conneries maintenant mais
c'est autre chose
je fais de la percussion avec mes pieds
et je crois que je fais craquer mes
orteils mais je fais bouger mes orteils
pour faire craquer mes chevilles
j'essaye tous les jours tu dois avoir
beaucoup plus de succès depuis que tu as
tellement minci que tu as ce look comme
ça très moderne et tout non tu tiens
trouve là
j'ai perdu du poids à 30 ans et puis
j'ai commencé si tu veux à
un canon mais bon
quand elle avait 30 ans les Québécois
disaient Fabienne Thibault c'est mes
deux chanteuses préférées
c'est bon Régine c'est un gros ballon
maintenant
pas du tout une catastrophe cette
histoire de pieds qui craque là je
trouve ça plutôt plutôt
rigolote la belle de Cadet
[Applaudissements]
cadixube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu